Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm slowly waking up because, like you guys know, it is a 12.30 stream, so I'm very tired.
I'm always tired in the morning.
Alright, story time!
Okay, you saw me react already on the chat, but like...
Okay, so like, I actually got really worried.
So like, the last couple of days...
Doki Amber Doge was like, not really into his food.
And I got really concerned because I was like, Oh no, is he getting sick?
So like, over the last couple of days, he was eating his food less and less enthusiastic.
And then, um, so he was just like... He was just like, he's just like, you know, he was like...
And then, okay, I should've got this as message yesterday.
Because like, I fed him yesterday for dinner.
And I fed him, and then he suddenly walked over to my door.
And he was like...
And I was like, why?
Like, I just fed you.
And I was so confused.
I was like...
Why are you angry at me?
So I walked out, because I was like, oh, maybe I need to refill his water.
Did I forget to refill his water?
Like, the automatic water dispenser was empty now.
So I walked over...
And then, I was like, and then he like, went to his food, looked at the food, looked at me, and started eating the rest of his food.
Because he wasn't eating it, he just... I walked over, and then he just started eating the rest of his food.
So I was like, oh, okay.
Maybe he was just feeling weird today.
He was just feeling a little quirky.
I was just like, oh, maybe he just wants a little attention.
That's why.
And then I went back to my PC.
I was like, maybe he just wants a little attention from me.
And I just went back to my PC to get back to work.
And then, and then...
And so, today, I was like, I was really worried today.
Because I fed him this morning, and then he had no reaction to his food this morning.
And I was so scared, because I was like, oh my god, why isn't he eating?
I was like, he has zero, he doesn't even go to his, he doesn't even go to his like, little bowl when I put food in it.
And, um, so then like, I got worried.
And I was like, oh, maybe he's just not, maybe he's like, maybe he's just trying to sunbathe, and he's not that hungry.
He just wants to relax a little more.
Like, I don't know, I was so tired.
He like, he didn't even wake me up.
The thing is, he didn't even wake me up in the morning to demand to be fed today.
Which was already weird, because he usually wakes me up in the morning to be like, FEED ME!
FEED ME!
And I would like, you know, I would begrudgingly wake up and like, feed him early in the morning, because I am whipped as fuck by my dog.
But he didn't do it.
So I like, you know, naturally woke up and saw him just like, sunbathing, like, um, in the living room.
And then he, and I fed him, and I went back to bed.
Like, I went back to bed.
And, uh, and then so like, and then I woke up at a more, you know, more natural time.
Like, you know, like 12 p.m.
I woke up, 12 p.m.
And I was like, alright, it's, it's, uh, okay, then, who am I kidding?
I didn't instantly go like, walkies time.
I laid in bed for 20 minutes, and, no, sorry, I laid in bed for 15 minutes, and then I was like, walkie time, walk, walk.
And I saw that, I saw that the food bowl was still full.
So I got really concerned.
I was like, oh my god, are you sick?
Like, like, you are the most food motivated motherfucker, like, dog I've ever owned.
So like, I was like, oh my god, is my dog sick?
Like, you're so food motivated, I don't understand.
Like, why is, why does this bowl still have food?
And then, so I was like, texting my friends, because I was freaking out, while I was on the walk too, because I was like, I have stream in 20 minutes, I was like, I have stream in 10 minutes.
I was like, texting my friends about this, while I was walking in, because I was trying to multitask, because I was like, oh, I have a stream in 10 minutes, oh fuck, okay, I need to figure this out.
I need to figure this out.
So, I was texting them, and then I was like, and while I was texting them, I was also Googling, I was like, oh, I left my dog food bag open for like, I think a week and a half now.
I was like, is that the reason why?
Like, is that, I like, left it open for a week and a half, is that why?
Because I know it's supposed to be sealed, but like, I, there were so many things going on, I forgot to seal it.
And every time, I was like, okay, I'm gonna seal it this time.
And then, so like, it's dry dog food, so I didn't realize, usually I would put it in a little box thing, like those like, dispensers.
So I was like, oh man, Bibi, is that the reason why?
And then, so like, so like, I do, I usually have those big plastic containers, but, um, but like, I recently opened this big dog bag, because he finished his old one.
And, oh, not recent, but like, the last week and a half, I didn't close it, because I was so tired.
I've been really tired lately, so like, I would just put my scooper in there, and then scoop it out from that, because like, it was too heavy.
It was like those giant bags, too.
It was like the biggest ones.
And like, and I was too, I couldn't, I can't lift it and pour it into the plastic container, because it was so, um, it was so big.
And then, so like, I was just like, so I just grab a scooper and just scoop it, and, but I just left the bag open.
And, um, and so like, I didn't realize dry food can, I didn't realize dog dry, because I Googled it, and then like, I was like, can dry dog food go stale?
Or like, I was like, can, I left, left dry dog food bag open.
I Googled it, and then, um, and then like, and then the Google was like, it can go stale and moldy.
And I was like,
I was like, I didn't, I was like, I
didn't know dry dog food,
you're supposed to, I was like,
oh my god.
So, so like, I don't know if the food is moldy, but it's definitely stale.
I, yeah, it's, it's definitely, um, it's definitely stale.
And so I was, I, I, I was like, oh, so I came back home.
Um, I came back home, and then like, I was just like, you know, I grabbed the dog food, and it was hard.
It was harder than it should be.
And then I like, I like, and then I was like, okay, and then my friends was like, try and give him treats and see if he, if he's eating.
And then I got the dog treats, like, you know, the sealed dog treats.
I, I, I gave the, the, the, the sealed dog treats, and then like, he like, I like, and then he instantly gobbled up.
He was like, I was like, oh, I'm so sorry.
And then, and then I picked up the dog, one piece of the dog food, and I gave it to him, and then he just sniffed it.
And he sniffed it, put it, he sniffed it, put it in his mouth, and then spit it out.
And I was like, I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, and he's like, and he just sniffs it, and he's like, nope, and then, bleh.
Right after the treats, because he thought it was another treat.
Oh my god.
I was like, oh my god, I didn't know.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't, I didn't know.
I thought because it was dry, it'd be okay, but I didn't know it could come still.
I thought I didn't know.
It was the first time I actually left a bag open, too.
Okay, but like, it's my, it is my fault.
I left it open for a week and a half.
I was going through a lot, so I was just like, oh, it can't be that bad.
And then now I, I don't know, I lost a lot of money now.
Because I, I bought those giant ass fucking bags, too.
So like, so like, it was even halfway done, and so I need to buy, I need to go and buy, buy like, another bag of dog food for him.
And then this time I will remember to seal the bag, to seal the bag next time so it doesn't go stale.
I, I was like, I didn't know.
I, I thought last night when he was parking at me and I thought, I don't know, I thought he wanted attention.
I didn't realize he was yelling at me for giving him shit food.
I, I didn't, I didn't know that's why he was yelling at me.
He gave me a warning.
He still ate the food last night, but he was, that was his last straw.
He was like, he was like, you know, I'll, because I like you, I'll still finish this food, but like, this is the last straw.
I'll eat it, but I'm still mad.
And then today he was like, did I not warn you?
Did I not tell you that, that this is not food anymore?
This morning he was, this morning he was just like, I thought I told you.
Oh my God.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I learned something new today.
I, I, I learned something new.
I, I do have the plastic container.
It was just so heavy.
I, it was a lot.
It was like the big dog food bags.
Like I bought the biggest one because in my mind, I was like, oh, if I buy the biggest one, I don't need to buy a refill later on.
So like, I couldn't fill the plastic container cause I can't fucking pick it up.
I had like my Uber driver bring the dog food bag.
I was like, if you, if you help me, if you help me bring it up to my apartment, I'll give you a tip.
So he brought the dog food bag up for me.
So I was just like, oh my God.
So yeah, uh, Zig thank you for the super chat.
Very first super chat.
Thank you.
My contribution to the dad food fund.
Give him some head pats for me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dark Ace, thank you for the super chat.
I didn't know!
I should have known food can go stale.
I, I don't know why I had like, um, I had like dog food as its own unique category.
I was like, of course food can go stale.
But then for some reason in my head, I saw like dry dog food as this like magical substance that could never go stale.
Like I was like, I was like, there's no way.
It's like magic food.
I've never, I've never heard about like dog, I don't know.
I just, I was like dogs will eat anything.
Like, you know, in my head I was like, dogs will eat anything.
There's no way it could go stale.
It's just, it's just, it's just dry food.
It's kibble.
Like, the fact that my very food motivated dog refused to eat it, I fucked up.
I, I, I would, I fucked up.
Like, you don't understand.
He is incredibly food motivated, but apparently he also has standards too.
So like, I was like, oh man.
So I learned something today.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for using my art as your thumbnail.
It's worth drawing at 12am because I'm so hyped you're streaming this game.
I hope you liked it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for drawing such a lovely, um, artwork for just for this stream.
Um, I would always, I'd always love to use artwork that's themed towards the stream.
So I really appreciate it when artists like draw something in anticipation for a stream that I'm going to be doing.
So thank you so much.
I'm really happy to be using it.
Um, yeah, so, um, I gave him some treats.
So I hope that that will sustain his hunger for now until I'm able to like go buy him actual food after.
So yeah, that's update number one.
Update number two.
I'm so fucking stupid because I didn't realize like, um, I didn't realize that like you don't need your passport to book like plane tickets and stuff.
So like, um, so like, uh, I was just like, oh yeah, I should like book some plane tickets to go somewhere.
And I won't say where.
But like, anyway, so then, cause I had to get my passport and I realized, wait, I could have booked this ticket like months ago for cheaper.
And I was just like, um, and I was like, cause like, I was like, where do I put the passport number?
But then you could, you do it later after you pay for the ticket.
And I did, I was like, oh my God, I could have saved money.
I could have, oh my God, I could have, I could have saved money.
I felt so fucking stupid.
I was like, oh my God, I'm so, I'm so sad.
I didn't know.
It's like you can, I didn't realize like, oh my God.
Anyway, there's been a lot of girl fail lately.
I'm so sad.
I was like, why didn't anyone tell me this?
I was like, I was like, oh my God.
I could have got this plane ticket a thousand dollars cheaper.
And I was like, oh man, I can't get my passport.
I can't, I can't book this yet.
I have to wait until I get my passport and like pick it up.
And then I'm like.
Anyway, Astro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad food fund contribution.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anton, you owe him a steak for this.
Yes.
I, I, yeah, I should have known.
I, oh my God.
Like I was like, that's why I thought he was sick.
Cause he's like incredibly food motivated.
So when he like doesn't want to eat the food, like something is wrong.
I was like, oh my God.
Like you don't want to eat.
What's wrong?
I was like, are you dying?
I was so scared.
I was like, is my dog dying?
Like I was so, I don't know.
I did not know what to do.
All right.
What is this game window?
The heart, the weirdest part is that, oh, it's called windows.
Okay.
I like, it had a weird name for the screen.
So let's play the game.
All right.
So needy streamer overload typing of the net.
So, oh my God, it's like I'm on an actual YouTube channel.
Oh my God.
All right.
So, oh, wait, it is search.
Doki bird.
Is there a Doki bird streamer in here?
I guess not.
I don't, I don't exist on this channel.
All right.
So apparently this is a spinoff of needy streamer overload typing of the net.
Oh, sorry.
It's called, it's a, I'm sorry.
My brain is like so frazzled right now after dealing with the goddamn panic thinking my dog was dying.
I was like so fucking scared.
And then I went through like three to four different spans of emotions within like 15 to 20 minutes.
Cause I was like trying to figure out what the fuck is going on with my dog.
And I'm like, my mind is like incredibly frazzled right now.
I was just like, I was so, so scared.
And then later I was like, oh, oh man, it was my fault.
I'm so sorry.
You warned me yesterday.
You fucking warned me.
You're like, you gave me this shit.
If I didn't know, I thought you just wanted attention.
Orca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, it is Orca day.
Can I get a, can an Orca get a big happy Orca day?
And fandom leave happy Orca day.
Yahoo.
Thank you for the super chat, Orca.
Thank you.
All right.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Orca.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Also, Johnny, Kush, and Han, thank you for the 10, 15 gifted ships.
Thank you.
So apparently this is a typing game, but like I did read the reviews and I found, cause like people were like, oh no, unsubscribe.
Um, I'm a lurk.
Did you know that like 30% of you guys aren't subscribed to my, I actually don't know this actual statistic.
But you know how like YouTubers were like, look at this graph.
30% of you aren't subscribed.
So press that subscribe button right now.
Well, like Nidistreamer, I don't know.
What's her name?
KaAngel.
It's been so long since I played Nidistreamer Overload.
But like, um, KaAngel has not impressed me yet.
She only has one video and like, um, I don't subscribe until like I see what her actual real personality is.
You know, you know how like, um, debut videos are not their real personalities until like, like, you know, debut me was so different from me now.
She just, yeah.
So I need like, I need two to three more videos until like I figure out who she, if she could be my Oshi.
Alright.
That's true.
That's, that's true.
Oh my gosh, my head.
Alright.
Hey, hey cuties.
Hello, it's KaAngel, your favorite tippy typing angel.
Guess what we're doing today.
We're exploring internet slang together.
Now get your keyboard ready and work those fingers.
It's gonna be super epic.
Ready?
Oh my god, wait.
Hater?
Nice.
Why do I have any?
I've never done anything wrong.
Geez, why was everyone so random and obs... what?
Coin, coin, some things.
Rule, excuse me?
Rule 34?
Lurker?
Someone reads post but rarely on, never post.
What?
Wait, what's this?
Khamij?
Eternal goat.
Okay.
Um, what am I learning?
What?
What am I?
Oh my god.
I can't even like, figure.
I can't even, I can't register the stuff I'm typing.
What happens when I see a smexy?
Stop?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, stop it.
Solo YOLO?
What are these new terms?
Am I getting old?
Geez.
Or like, are they like, stuff that like, older people are putting in this game?
She just like for, she's just like me for real.
For real, for real.
Oh, the faster I type, the more viewers she gets.
All for my oshi, all your... Okay, this is definitely some old guy that... I'm sorry, I'm not old.
That is definitely old internet slang.
Uh...
Well then, let's take it up a notch.
Alright, you can handle it, right?
I mean, that's really easy.
Keep up or you're gonna get pwned.
Skill issue?
That can't be me.
Something I would never have...
True kai angel.
I remember when that was a thing for conventions, and like, people actually broke their bones, cause like, random stranger would like, glomp each other out of nowhere.
And then so like, glomping became banned in conventions.
Isn't that like, an old internet term?
Normies have money!
Cause they have jobs!
How dare you?
I'm technically like, a normie.
It's more likely than you think.
Oh my God.
Mother of God.
It's hard to like, talk and like, she goes so fast.
Can't be me.
Oh my God, view count go up.
Vanity search?
Oh, everyday.
It's called ego searching.
My friends always tell me to stop ego searching.
They judge me every time.
I just go on Twitter and be like...
Recent tweets.
What's my score?
Oh nice, S.
Almost S rank.
Stop.
I told you guys, I read everything.
I read like, recent tweets.
I always see what you guys are trying to tweet out and post.
Alright, she still hasn't impressed me yet, guys.
I don't know, I don't know if I want to subscribe to her right now.
I'm still not impressed with her content enough to be a subscriber.
Alright, level 2.
Goat typing battle with Ca-Angel and those haters.
Nice.
Like... Oh God.
Okay.
I'm like going through like... Oh, this is like 2010.
Oh wait, did I die?
Okay guys, I should focus.
It won't even let me commentate!
She won't let me commentate!
She's like, I'm the streamer here.
Why are you talking to your chat?
This is my chat now.
Okay guys, actually, she won't let me commentate.
She won't let me do commentary.
I just have to focus up.
Alright, give me a sec.
I'm locking in, guys.
I'm locking in.
She won't be the better streamer.
Your argument...
She won't let me stream!
She won't let me be a streamer!
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm locking in.
Alright, let's fast forward this.
Let's fast... She has... I can't even fast forward.
Alright, I'm locked in this time.
It's Kai Angel's stream now.
Alright, it's super fun.
IRC channel?
Wait, what's an IRC channel?
I feel old.
Wait, what is an IRC?
I actually don't know.
Ragebait?
That's what I do everyday.
No, sorry, those are Twitch... Those are some Twitch streamers.
Jilted?
I'm not.
Checky?
Oh, I know what Checky is.
Katasha?
Sage?
This feels so 2010 right now.
Some of these I recognize from like 20... Oh, oh, she!
That's me!
Just... According... To... Hikkaku.
What?!
Okay, I typed it in time.
Creepypasta.
That was... This is aging me.
Press F to pay respects.
I actually don't know what game that was originally for.
Mods are asleep.
Sage is like 2003.
I remember Sage from Neopets.
Let's take it up a notch.
You can handle this.
Keep up or you're gonna get pawned.
Wubi?
Wubi.
Yaoi paddle?
Oh, God.
Things I'm glad are not a thing anymore.
Ujoshi.
Not me.
That's not me, guys.
I swear to God.
Squee.
Leap.
Lolita.
That was my past, okay?
I will admit, that was my past, but I'm reformed.
I'm a reformed Fujo.
I discovered gaming.
Okay, on the internet.
That feel when... When I beat this game.
Shitposting.
Oh, that's what I do every day, honestly.
Even for, like, sponsoring.
Nice.
Wow, you're a lot better than I thought.
Pretty base and epic, in fact.
All that shitposting really popped off.
Oh, God.
You're so cringe, Kai Angel.
If I could, I might just block you instead.
Instead of subscribing to her, I might just block her.
What was it?
Do not recommend this channel.
Hey, cuties.
It's Kai Angel, your favorite angel.
Guess what we're doing today?
We're exploring internet slimes together.
Now, get your keyboard ready and work those fingers.
It's gonna be super epic and super fun.
Go, Lurkmore.
Do this before you post.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Guys, I can't.
She won't let me commentate anymore.
She won't let me be a streamer anymore.
Oh, it's so much faster.
Okay.
Alright.
I heard you like...
No, fuck!
Ah!
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm... okay.
We're fine.
I don't do well in pressure situations.
The laws...
Green text...
Pwned...
Oh, I'm locking in.
I'm locking in.
I'm pre-typing too now.
Problematic...
Can't be me.
I'm the most unproblematic fave.
It's...
Oh, and then you have to add numbers into a typing game!
Oh, what's this?
Alright, nice.
Forever alone.
Is that it?
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
Well then, let's take it up a notch.
You can handle this, right?
Keep up or you're gonna get pwned.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Om nom nom.
Alright.
LARPing.
New achievers are the strongest.
Oh, shit.
Problem...
What's belated?
No, um, beli...
Oh, sh...
No!
I was... I wanted to know what...
I was so curious!
I was like, what is that word?
I...
I wanted to know what that word meant!
I actually wanted to learn!
I actually wanted to learn, guys.
I was like, belated?
The fuck is that?
I've never heard of that word before.
Okay.
Ready and super fun.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, I can't even learn?
I thought this was learning about internet slang.
But it won't... she won't even let me learn.
She's like, just type this.
I'm like, yes, queen, I will.
Akimakura.
Oh, the one time I was like, I wonder what that means.
Noob.
Say so.
Me.
Oh, I know you are not...
Oh, really?
In before...
Wo... Wojack?
Wait, what's Wojack?
What's... what's Wojack?
Some of these are like, fucking terrible descriptions.
Doom scrolling.
Oh, I...
Twitter right now.
Problematic.
Zettai Ryukyai?
No...
I was so confused.
Words I don't know.
I was like, how to spell?
You can handle this, right?
Keep up, you're gonna get pwned, Yuri.
Means lily, but also...
Oh, shit.
Why was it that way?
Sorry, it like, threw me off.
The four letter word threw me off.
I was like, wait, excuse me?
I don't know why.
They're like, spell dealt and I...
I type every letter except for the right letters.
I was like, oh.
The cake is alive.
Good night.
Sweet prince.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, nice.
Notice me, senpai.
Alright.
Mom, holy fuck?
Kicks down the...
Oh, that's the cadence meme.
Wow, you're a lot better than I thought.
Pretty based and epic, in fact.
All that shit posting really paid off.
Now go.
Sally Fork, my little internet explorer.
Show the sweet summer child who the goat poster is.
Bless.
Yay!
Okay, I will admit, I think it was the dill part that fucked me up.
Alright, streams...
Okay, I know streams not...
So, apparently, you guys might be thinking, that's it?
That's...
It's only a 37 minute game?
Do not leave.
Because I found out that...
There's actually more to this game.
So a lot...
I was reading it, because I was very surprised.
Because I was like, wow.
Why is there, like, mixed reviews?
And then people were like...
People were giving...
And I was reading the reviews.
So there were people like, this is too short.
I can't believe I paid $9 for three levels.
And...
Okay, mostly it was a 10 minute game.
And so, like, people were like...
Oh, man.
Because I was getting worried.
I usually don't read reviews, if it's positive.
So I was like, oh, shit.
So, people...
People apparently didn't click Endless Nightmare at the end.
They didn't...
They didn't look at...
At the end, where it says Endless Nightmare.
And so people were like...
People just instantly closed the game and refunded it.
And...
So...
Because I was wondering why it had negative reviews.
And that's the only reason when I...
That's the only reason I'll read reviews.
Because I'd be like, why is this game garbage?
Because I was confused.
Because it's Needy Girl Overdose.
Like, why the fuck would they release a 10 minute game?
So...
So, like...
So, in the reviews, people were like...
If you see negative reviews, they skipped the credits.
I was like, oh, okay.
That's interesting.
They skipped the credits.
What do they mean by that?
Alright.
So, now...
Now, it's a platformer game.
Oh, you don't even see it.
Open a new browser.
Alright.
Anyway...
Now...
Now, it's an entirely new game that I'm playing.
Now, I'm playing a new game, guys.
Alright.
Let's see...
Windows size.
Actually, let's...
Let's make this bigger for my...
Fucking...
For my sake.
Alright, let's fix this.
Oh, my god.
Kai Angel.
I hate it when you have to make me change my resolution.
Alright.
So, yeah.
Now, we're playing a platformer game.
Game number two.
Now, this is epic like a boss.
Cas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Evo, Kai Angel.
So, yeah.
Now, I'm on the platformer game.
Hello.
Wait, I have a chainsaw?
Okay.
Alright.
There's...
There's a projectile.
Alright.
I have...
I actually don't know what it really is about other than the fact that it's a platform...
Oh, my god!
Oh, jump.
Okay, thank you.
Alright.
Jumping.
Double jump.
Okay.
There's a double jump.
Apparently, this platformer is extremely hard, too.
Okay.
Jump goes through.
Nice.
Sis.
Slash, slash, slash.
Jade.
Go up by collecting items.
Drop.
But that's like the only thing I know so far about the second game.
The second hidden game.
Is there any sound?
There is.
It's just...
The only sound is me jumping and the slash.
Okay, nice.
Oop.
So easy.
I'm just gonna use my projectile.
Uh, throw a knife.
Dodge.
Oh, whoop.
The power's decreased if your gauge reduces.
Oh, shit!
Oops.
Whoops.
I didn't realize that that requires power.
Oopsie.
That's fine.
I have more power here.
Hello.
Hello, evil me.
Oop.
But how is this platformer hard?
Why do people say this took a long time to beat?
Oh, no.
Use one unit of your gauge to heal?
Oh, it's like...
It's like Hollow Knight.
Hello?
You're literally in the tutorial.
How many levels is there?
Stage 1?
Up the sound effects a little bit?
Okay.
I just need you to know there's like no option menu.
When you're in the...
When you're in the second game, there is...
Oh, shit.
Now they can do projectile.
Okay, that's a little bad.
Oh, that's where the...
Oh, what?
You touched me one time!
Oh.
It's fine.
Okay.
I don't want him getting near me.
Because apparently, like, even like a little poke can fuck me up.
Okay.
Oh, I can like...
I can slide.
Wait, it never taught me slide?
Dash.
Oh.
Wait, this is so much faster.
It never even taught me...
Oh.
It's fine.
They're just little babies.
Nothing to worry about.
Look at that.
Just a little baby.
Can't even move.
Look at that.
You have no free will.
Look at you.
You're so weak.
I could literally just stay there and then up the volume of my game.
Alright, I upped it a little bit.
This is a boss fight?
I can literally just stay there and up the volume.
What's this?
I have like a shirt at the bottom right.
But it hasn't told me what it is yet.
Whoa!
Secret!
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I got the shirt.
There's the shirt.
What the heck is this shirt?
I don't want to use it.
Because it didn't tell me what it does.
Okay.
I'm just worried about my shirt.
Is it collectible?
What happens if I click it?
Oh, it doesn't do it.
Oh, it is a collectible.
I thought if I click it, something would happen.
Alright.
How do I...
Wait, how do I get my health back?
How do I get my health back?
Is this like...
You can use your gauge?
Wait, what?
What do I press?
What do I press to hold E?
Oh, it's E!
Okay, it's E.
Alright.
Oh.
That's easy.
Is there a secret on the other side?
Why is it like that?
No?
What?
There's not even a secret on the other side.
Hello?
Oh, shit!
It's a cat!
Hello, cat.
Oh!
Oh, it's an evil cat!
It's an evil cat!
Oh, is he dead?
Oh!
No!
Wait, I can just tank this.
Oh!
Hardest boss fight of my goddamn life!
Oh my God, this is so hard!
Proceed, please.
Just face tank it.
That's my...
That's how I play every game.
Stage 2.
Okay, so there's five stages.
Hello, cat!
Jada charge...
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Okay.
Alright, so now I have a charge attack.
What's this?
Touch the glowing wall while charging up to climb it?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's like...
Oh, that's so cool!
Okay, I like these new mechanics.
Up I go.
Oh, I can damage people too.
What are you gonna do?
Kill me?
Oh, wait, this is so broken!
I can literally just do that.
Oh, shit!
Never mind.
I shouldn't do that.
That's actually a waste of my power-ups.
Hey, I would be a Mega Man now.
Oh, shit.
While climbing, hold and then when I move in, jump to the other side.
Oh, wall climb.
Wall jumps.
Okay, this way.
Oh, this is like...
Not as smooth as I think it is.
Yeah, there's like low damage for the wall climb shit.
Like...
The damage is not that high for when you're walking up.
But it's really high when you're...
It's really high during wall climbing.
Not during the actual fight itself.
Crouch while jump.
Charging up to move quickly.
While you're moving quickly, hold where direction and press to long jump.
Oh!
Oh, my god!
I'm so fucking fast!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I'm not used to it.
I'm not used to how fast I'm moving.
Wait.
There we go.
God, fuck.
Okay.
No.
Please.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh, my god.
This is not...
I can't.
This is not natural for me.
It's not natural.
God damn it!
Okay.
Okay, I can do this.
It's just...
It's just not natural.
I'm like so disoriented.
Okay.
And then...
God damn it.
Please.
Be that secret.
Okay.
This tech is weird.
This is a very weird tech.
Are you serious?
How am I not making that jump?
Alright.
I got this.
I just need more momentum.
Right here.
Okay.
Alright.
I need a whole jump.
I need to do a double jump.
Okay.
Here we go.
I got the momentum.
Nice.
Okay, I did it.
First try.
I keep forgetting to double jump.
It's so hard.
You guys don't understand.
Okay.
Okay, nevermind.
I think I do not like this mechanic.
I'm so sorry.
Guys, can you tell I'm not a platform player?
Guys, is it noticeable?
Is it noticeable, guys?
Guys, is it...
Don't laugh.
Is it...
No, right?
Because I'm such a fucking gamer.
It's not right, guys.
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to figure out how to get up here now.
Okay.
Oh, I figured it out.
Oh my god.
No!
Please!
I am...
You nice?
Oh my god.
Please!
Okay, I just...
I don't know why my mind isn't, like, alive.
My mind isn't...
My mind doesn't know what to do.
My mind doesn't know what to do in wall jumps.
I died.
Okay.
Okay, we did it.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
I hope there's not more of this part.
Oh man, it'll be so unfortunate the game adds more.
No, man, think about 20 gifted ships they could take you.
That would be so unfortunate.
Oh hey, there's another heart.
Oh, it's a bunny.
Can I face tank you too?
Oh no.
Oh no, don't do this to me.
Does this hurt me?
No, we're fine.
Don't do this to me.
Okay, nice.
It's not that hard.
Okay, he just shoots the ray and the center.
And with my speed, it'll be okay.
Slow and steady wins the race, guys.
Slow and steady.
Oh shit.
Guys, slow and steady wins the race.
Okay, let's go.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Thank God.
No!
Okay,
I figured it out.
Alright, just one more hit.
Oh shit, what?
How does this go?
Okay.
Okay, okay, give me a sec.
I'm downloading.
I'm downloading this right now.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
God damn it!
I'm just gonna tank this.
I have enough HP.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Yo, human versus gravity.
I just... I don't know.
My brain just can't fucking comprehend.
It just doesn't comprehend wall riding for some reason.
Like, it's like... My brain is like, this is unnatural.
This is a work against physics.
And I'm like, you're right.
That's how... I'm like, you're so right, brain.
That's actually unnatural.
Physics should not work there.
Anyway.
Oh, I have to...
Close the eyes.
And then go here.
Can I use my chainsaw for it?
Or... Yeah, I can.
Okay, I didn't want to waste my...
I didn't want to waste my...
My power move here.
My range.
If I can just use the chainsaw.
Hello there.
Hello there, you unnatural freak.
Yay, I fly now.
At least they give me this instead.
Okay, that's fine.
I don't mind killing them while they're in the air.
I'll just face tank it, as always.
Like, they just do one damage, so I'm not scared.
I thought this game was about typing.
Oh, you didn't look at the... Me too.
I was just so excited about a typing game too.
But like... Oh, hey.
Did it actually hurt me this time?
Wait, what?
Oh, it's like a...
I don't know, I feel like...
I might play Typing of the Dead in the future.
Because I actually really like typing games.
But then I realized it's so hard to talk while you type.
Like, she barely let me try and commentate because she's like, I'm the streamer here.
Kat Angel doesn't even let me talk.
She's like, how fucking dare you take over my stream.
Okay, let me figure out this first.
Alright.
A lot of these enemies aren't actually a threat because they're just like giant fodder for me to chainsaw.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's a little cheap because he landed on me.
Yeah, all typing, no yapping.
She's like, excuse me, I'm the Yoshi here.
Alright.
Nice.
I just think that wall riding one was like...
The wall riding one was like...
Like, this is so much easier than...
I don't know.
Am I bad?
No, I'm not bad.
I'm a streamer.
I'm not bad.
This is my channel.
I don't know.
I just think the wall riding one was definitely a lot harder than this level.
I knew it.
I knew there was a secret there.
It was so predictable.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Nice.
Wait, is this another secret entrance to somewhere?
Where does this go?
Hello?
Okay.
Wait, what?
I just keep...
No, no, no, come on.
Go up, go up, go up.
Go up.
Nice.
Yippee!
Okay, we got another secret.
Wait, why would I need to close his eyes?
Huh?
Why would his eyes ever need to be closed?
Okay, I don't understand.
I don't understand why...
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Wait.
What?
Huh?
I have to close the eyes down there, but how?
What?
Okay, so I do have to close it, but how?
I just use the dash?
What?
Wait, how do I...?
Oh, does the chainsaw go through this?
Oh, it does!
Oh, okay.
Okay, I now know.
I'm learning, guys.
I'm learning.
Look, I'm sorry.
My hand needs to be held.
Or I'll never learn.
It has to be directly in my face and be like, Doki, you gotta do this.
And I'll be like, okay.
Okay.
They need to, like, put it in front of my face.
And be like, this is how you play the game.
And I'll be like, thank God.
Where is my yellow?
Exactly, where the fuck is my yellow paint?
Alright, can I face tank this, too?
I have, like, literally three power-ups.
Like, three healers.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, wait.
It's just a dolphin.
Or I can just be here.
I can just be in the middle.
Oh, shit!
I can't beat him!
Guys, apparently, I cannot just be in the middle yet.
What the fuck?!
Wait, how do I...
Okay, nice.
Okay, guys.
Apparently, this dolphin is not just gonna sit there and let me beat the shit out of him.
Like...
Understandable.
Like, who wouldn't want to just get, like, chainsawed to death?
Okay, nice.
I can't believe... I can't believe he wouldn't just, like, sit there and just let me do this to him.
Alright, nice.
Get over here.
Wait, I can't even reach him.
Okay.
Alright, where is he going?
Where is he going?
Here.
That's fucking right!
Let me beat the shit out of you!
That's right!
You think I won't take this?!
I'm too dumb to realize how to dodge!
That's fucking right!
I'm way too dumb!
Okay, I can't do anything about it, though.
Okay, 50.
That's a fucking rough face to take this!
Get over here!
I'm gonna start swinging!
Oh, I heard dolphin meat is pretty good!
Get over here!
I'm in a chain!
That's right.
To be fair, they're like a menace to society anyway.
So, like, nothing is actually lost if we eat a dolphin.
You think they're cute?!
They're actual, like, they're like the...
They're like criminals of the ocean world.
They're like the mafia.
The mafia of the ocean world.
They literally will, like...
They actually can, like, take other sea creatures hostage.
Or, like...
Or, like, commit crime.
They murder for fun.
Yeah, they're one of the few...
They're also one of the few animals in the world that, like, bang for fun.
Like, for pleasure.
Like, a lot of...
You know, like, a lot of the animals in the...
A lot of the animals in the, like...
In the...
In the world are, like, reproduction, you know?
But dolphins are, like, pleasure.
There's no laws in the ocean, exactly.
They're like, wait a minute.
This is fun.
But, like, they're one of the few...
They're one of the few animals that actually realize that, like, it's more than just, like, babies.
There's...
There's no laws in the ocean, exactly.
Get over here.
Come on, one more swing.
I know you just need one more.
Okay, maybe two more swings.
Maybe three more swings.
Get over here.
What if I...
No, I can't.
Alright, I'll just wait.
Oh my god, please.
He's literally one.
There we go.
Wait, what?
Okay, now he's literally one?
What?
Okay, now he's literally one.
There's no way he's not one now.
There's no way.
Yay!
Alright, nice.
Okay, we're at stage four.
Get up for stage four!
What is this?
He's literally one, guys.
It's like when I play, like, competitive shooters and I'm like, he's literally one, guys.
And he was actually half HP.
But, like...
You say that so people would, like, shoot him so he could be one later.
And then I'll just do that, right?
Yeah.
Goddammit, wait, what?
Do I...
Do I do this?
And then...
Do I do?
Wait, what?
How do I hit that?
Yeah, he's one if you shoot at him enough, exactly.
I'm talking about one in the future.
How do I...
I'm, like, trying to figure out.
Yeah, because I can't do that in time.
How?
Yeah, because I can't make that.
I can't make that in time.
Hello?
What?
Oh, okay.
Do I just charge it?
Oh my God, I...
This is exposing me.
This game is exposing me and I don't like it.
You guys are like, oh no, thank God we didn't vote for her for Gamer of the Year.
Doki, that's exactly why you didn't get nominated.
You can't be Gamer of the Year if you're only good at one genre.
I'm, like, ow!
I'm so confused!
I'm actually so confused.
Why can't I do anything?
Okay, I figured this out.
I figured this out.
I can't do this.
I don't know.
Guys, please.
I'm so confused.
Where's the yellow pin?
Guys, I don't understand.
Oh my God.
Okay, double jump after the charge.
Oh my God, I'm so smart, guys.
I always knew.
I knew what I was doing.
Okay.
So easy.
Oh shit, okay.
Let's do this.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, don't.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
Oh my God, natural.
I'm a natural.
Where does this go?
What is this?
That's my OG, everybody.
Milanta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, it wasn't brute force.
I naturally knew what to do.
Oh my God, please.
Please.
Oh, please, please, please.
Please, I don't understand.
Please.
Please!
Why did they bring me back?
Okay, I understand.
I understand now.
Look at that.
The first try.
It's so smooth.
So smart.
Wait, there's something over here.
What's over here?
It won't let me go down.
What the fuck was over there?
Yeah, I knew there was something over here.
Oh, okay, never mind.
It was just welcome back to hell.
Alright, so if you fuck up, you have to do this all over again.
But that's the best part.
I would not fuck up.
That's the best part.
I would not fuck up, guys.
Oh my God, please.
Get me out of here.
Get me out of the wall right now.
Please, I don't...
Please.
Get me out.
This is the worst mechanic.
This is the worst mechanic they have.
Okay.
Oh my God, Buzz!
Buzz, let me back out!
Alright, we can do this.
We can do this.
Right here, right now.
Okay, not now.
Not now, but right here.
Okay, right here.
I think now.
Oh my God, yes.
Okay.
There you go.
I told you, right here, right now.
I told you, right here, don't.
Please, don't do this to me.
Okay.
Put him, put him back on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, thank God, I figured it out.
Alright, nice.
We got another Tetris piece.
How far do I- How many do I have to do?
Do I, like, put them in now?
No, I have to get all the Tetris pieces.
Alright.
That can't be that bad, right?
Okay, now that I got the hard ones off...
Things would be easier now.
I got the harder levels away now, guys.
This part is super easy.
Okay, just...
Give me a sec.
I'll get there eventually, guys.
Just- It's like three to four business days, but I'll get there.
Okay, apparently not.
Alright, I touched it.
Nice.
I told you, three to four business days.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Wait.
Wait, wait.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Right here, and then...
What?
Okay, nice.
I figured it out.
And then...
Wait, what?
Oh, okay, I do- I jump...
And then I use my powers here, and then...
Okay, alright, that's not it.
But like, I jump...
And then...
And- Oh my god, please.
Okay, I jump...
I- I- I jump...
And then...
Okay...
And then from here...
Oh my god, please.
Alright, I jump...
And then from here...
And then...
Oh my god, I am a fucking gamer.
That's fucking right.
That's me.
The hard part's done.
Nice, alright.
See, look at that.
That was so much easier than the fucking wall ride.
I just don't know.
My mind just...
My mind just can't, like...
Comprehend, like...
Wall jumping.
It just feels so unnatural.
My brain is like...
This is- This goes against all laws of aviation.
The fuck are these babies doing here?
Like...
They're so weak.
I should- I should use this one so I can get my full HP now.
We're so slow though.
I don't like how slow we are.
Is it supposed to be slow?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I'm supposed to be slow as fuck.
Alright.
Next level.
Wait, that was it?
They were like...
Unarmed and everything.
Yeah, I know.
I was like, they were unarmed.
They were just babies.
Alright.
Let's get this power up.
Yeah!
I got the secret.
Yippee!
I feel like I'm gonna die.
I feel like I'm getting slower and slower.
But I don't know if it's my game.
Oh, hey.
Hello.
Are you the boss right now?
I'm gonna kill you.
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna take it.
That's how I'm gonna kill you.
You think I learned how- Oh, fuck!
You think I learned how to dodge this entire time?
Let's go!
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
Okay, this is awkward now.
It's alright.
I still killed you.
Who needs to do mechanics?
There you go.
Stage 5.
I didn't pay exactly.
I didn't pay $9 to fucking dodge.
I should have everything.
Oh, my god.
I'm Kaenjo now.
Hello.
Wait, what?
Hold to charge it up.
Okay, I don't wanna waste my charge up though.
Wait, unless I do?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, I'm not wasting that.
Wait, are we like Touhou now?
Is this Touhou?
Mental illness?
Why?
Oh, no.
Oh, it is Touhou.
Oh, it is.
Okay, I need to like charge it up to...
Oh, I should not leave people die.
What is this game?
Now I'm in Touhou?
I'm just gonna hold this for now.
Oh, shit.
That's so much damage.
Oh, it's side scroll.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, bullet hell.
Exactly.
I see bullet hell.
Is this Touhou?
Alright.
Goodbye.
I'm just gonna be full HP just in case.
Nice.
Okay, goodbye.
I'm gonna AD strafe just in case.
Don't worry, this AD strafe will be helpful later on.
You just don't understand.
Okay, I took damage because I was AD strafing, but you don't understand.
It will be useful.
Oh, god.
Oh, that's way too many things.
And then...
I need to...
Make sure I get past this in time.
Yay, I lived!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
It's fine.
I still lived.
Trust the process.
I'm dodging bullets like this.
Trust the process, guys.
I'm practicing for Marvel Rivals tomorrow.
Trust the process.
Oh, my god.
There's so many things on my screen.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Okay, that's me, but evil.
I'm just gonna...
I didn't learn.
What do you think I learned?
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should learn.
You're doing...
You're doing a lot of damage.
Whoa!
What is this?
Okay.
It's fine.
That's not fine.
Whoa.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Okay, now that I know...
Oh, my god.
Like, I barely...
Do I need to charge this up?
Okay, maybe.
Oh, okay.
I have to do that.
Okay.
I realize now.
Oh, okay.
Now it's Touhou.
Now it's Touhou, guys.
Now...
This is definitely Touhou now.
This is...
Oh, this is definitely Touhou.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, I think I'm actually in Touhou.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Okay, buddy.
Alright, calm down.
Calm down.
Oh, I did not...
I'm not...
I'm not ready for Touhou.
I'm just gonna say it.
I am 100% never ready when it's Touhou.
I do not know what to do when it's Touhou.
I'm not a Touhouer.
I didn't grow up with Touhou.
I'm sorry.
I'm fake.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, what is he doing?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Alright.
Is he dying?
Oh, wait.
He's like dying while doing that.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Woah.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, goodbye.
Toki is sad now.
Yay, I did it!
Did I win?
How the fuck did you know to spam tap?
It says J.
If I see a key button, I tap.
Is that it?
Wait, this was so easy.
People in the reviews were like...
The last level was so hard.
I can never...
It's so hard to beat the last level.
Bro, I'm not even the Touhou-er.
I don't even Touhou.
Wait, that's it?
What?
Okay.
You know, I expected the last level to be a lot harder.
Okay, wait, wait.
I need you guys to see the reviews for this.
People were like, Oh man, that last level was so difficult.
I'm like, what?
What?
Let's see.
People were like...
The person who thought was probably saying, What do you mean?
Seven years for such a short gameplay?
I mean, it looks cool, but...
For three levels!
It's not just three levels.
It was actually six levels.
And...
My fingers hurt.
We're not real gamers.
Yeah, that was the last level.
To be fair, at least it wasn't...
To be fair, at least it wasn't like...
Just the...
Just the typing game.
Because then, the typing game was literally ten minutes of content.
At least we got an hour out of this.
At least...
At least we...
I'm glad we got an hour out of this game, at least.
You know?
An hour worth of gameplay.
And, anyway, tonight...
We still have a second stream tonight, anyway.
So, at least...
At least we have a second stream.
Yeah, I was...
Very surprised how easy it was.
I heard some people were saying the last level was gonna be really hard.
And I was like, that's it?
I was like, bro, I don't even Touhou.
I'm not even a Touhou-er.
That was so easy!
What's sound test?
Oh, I think it was just...
It was just to test the music out to see if you liked the volume.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
We beat Touhou.
We did it, guys.
Oh my god.
I can't believe that.
That was a short stream, guys.
I had a great time.
At least I have time to buy dog food.
At least now.
At least now I have time to buy dog food before Toraba.
But yeah, this is like a little appetizer, I guess.
We got a little appetizer before tonight.
We do have a second stream tonight with Toraba, the creating game.
So I'll see you guys tonight for that.
And tomorrow, we do have a stream tomorrow on Sunday with Doobie.
So we're going to be playing Marble Rivals tomorrow on Sunday with Doobie at 5pm PST.
So get ready to be there.
Oh, she's...
Spark, the story for pre...
Sorry, my brain is so frazzled today.
Like, you can tell I'm stumbling words and I don't know what to say today.
Because, like, legitimately, like...
I went through so many...
Like, when I go through a lot of emotions in a short...
In a short amount of time...
Like, I just don't know what to say.
Like, my mind takes slower...
It takes slower to process things.
Or, like, longer to process...
It takes longer for me to process things.
And my mind is, like, stumbling and buffering a lot.
Because I legitimately thought my dog was dying.
But it's because I gave him stale food and he's like...
She's like, the fuck is this, bitch?
Like...
He's like, excuse me.
I am a purebred pedigree wiener dog.
And you expect me to eat stale food?
And then, like, you know, I...
So, like...
So, like, I was freaking out about that for a while.
Hey, guys.
I'm gonna go buy dog food now.
So my dog doesn't starve.
I'll see you guys next...
I'll see you guys tonight, everybody.
As always, everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And stay up for me?
Stay up a little longer, because I do have another stream at 5 PM.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
Also, I realized I could've finished the platformer section, like, legitimately 30 minutes earlier.
If, like, my brain understood the game breaking physics during wall...
If I understood wall jumping.
I just... I can't.
I don't know why.
My brain is like...
This should not work...
Like, this should not work in real life.
I see wall jumping and my brain cannot compute.
And it's like...
This breaks all laws of physics.
How dare you?
Fucking witchcraft.
Hey, guys.
See you, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!